la tutti ragazzi e benvenuti che sono
video sono felice oggi sono tornati sul
gioco diverso dal solito non sono 103
episodi lo farò lo speciale 200 tra
qualche secolo facciamo il primo livello
ragazzi si svolge tra unispace perché in
space a a questo lo spaccio un gusto no
scusami non avevano proprio dubbi zio
che questo fosse lo spazio bravissimo
cioè una riproduzione incredibile nello
spazio ai complimenti perché lo si
succhia il pollice
l'importante è che ho vinto poi
chissenefrega comunque complimenti per
la riproduzione nello spazio in hd 1080
culi grassi parco rto eto'o figli
andrete ad esplorare i grassi park
va bene che cazzo adesso grassi park il
parco degli obesi stato bello
siamo partiti già cappottati mi casa
proprio bravi a far parkour non siamo
neanche partiti gritti e meraviglioso
dal è perfetto salve
non è giornata oggi ragazzi quindi
vedete di farmi fare le cose per bene
questo è successo che cazzo di parco è
tutto al contrario non ho le gambe come
sono bravo a fare parkour senza gambe
sarà vero giorno devo fare mi spiegate
dove sta la parte del parkour all'altro
ho capito e la sedia la sedia il parkour
come come faccio a pedalare come
possibile che quest'uomo pedali ancora
non è possibile c'è dai spiegano ecco
adesso mi sa che non riesco neanche più
a fare bunga bunga il che potrebbe
essere un problema
tutto a posto zio non sta malissimo
riproviamoci lega che non ho capito la
parte del parkour dove stava perché non
c'è nessun party wets ea quella come
faccio il parkour comun riproviamo a
regà vi dovete levare al cazzo ne avete
capito il senso della vita bravo luke
aicarr lui ha capito solo liuc per ora
manca chi si sta candidando cosa faccio
io per farmi staccare le gambe qual è il
problema
devo vincere l'asta partita perché la
mia gamba sinistra continua a pedalare 6
staccata dal mio corpo
e vabbè facciamo finta di niente
voi non avete visto niente testi your la
stessa la tua fortuna quando faccio
questi io perdo sempre che c'è un motivo
in teoria ci provo ai ragazzi non ancora
provate a fare un livello ma davanti in
via che culo perfetto eva beato stronzo
io no vabbè ma non ci posso credere o no
va bene che è tornata pure indietro cioè
per prendermi pure per il culo cioè
fantastico niente raia ce l'ho fatta
l'importante questo rende folle oddio
che che salto fatto ma devo andare
ma dovrà prendere la moneta scusate la
potevo prendere sono io scemo che non
l'ho presa non ci arrivo a sperare che
ci arrivano a fermi ci arriva se mi
impegno tipo adesso sto come l'ho presa
fatto una gran figura di merda ce la
posso fare ma dai non fa niente senza
senzamoneta fottitene palleggia col
casco braulio aia ok ok
però mai fermi ragazzi come si può
prendere la moneta perché mica non è
possibile
c'è prima la stavo per prendere che non
volevo prenderla come ho fatto a non
prenderla e va bene che salto era non ce
la faccio non c'è poca dire niente stavo
scherzando non si può prendere st moneta
non so come ho fatto all'inizio ma
niente non avete visto niente
with a j cazzo vuol dire che stanno
stuprando la j ragazzi dunque facciamo
che devo andare su win tipo subito
grazie ai veneti ne ascoltano in gioco
quando io faccio tanti livelli di è più
tra fine si tagliano il cazzo anche
livelli stessi e mi ascoltano per farmi
vincere prima per farmene va dai maroni
8 bit e ryan pixel quanto figo cos'è
quella roba lì by orange sky perché c'è
una merda o un sasso non so se la merda
vale non lo so ragazzi questo è un
livello ad aa 8 bit
mi sembra la cosa più [ __ ] dell'india a
terra quella una moneta non l'aveva che
figata è se solo sapesse giocare i
videogiochi parlamenti all'obiettivo e
prendere le monete in questo fatemi
capire don't say to long on the platform
perché sa perché crollano ste cose
bastardi non ci arrivo
[Musica]
e fa bene son patto giù con un
deficiente vai vai vai vai vai vai
veloce giro veloce il casca tutto sì sì
sì perfetto dato che volessimo userspace
più shift jump tiger è che ne sapevo io
di questa cosa ragazzi ma veramente non
saremmo qua si poteva fare sulla pista
quanto tempo io non lo sapevo ma do cosa
ho fatto
dove devo andare di sopra con shift non
ha ma io non lo sapevo sta cosa ragazzi
ma su sì però di vista regata stai calmo
chi cazzo se sai pianificando di
uccidermi il grande pixel burger
tu sei sapesse saresti di grande pizza
burger oh merda ma come lo su chi spam
click on this devo cliccare qua per
ucciderlo ma bello che morte strana ed è
che cosa mi rappresenta sandel i rami
svegliate il senso di questo libro è
figo alto livello per carità però non ha
capito il senso pesoli e 8 pixel burgo
di ho trovato l'ultima moneta lega ce
l'ho ce l'ho io che sono forte falchi
era botto run lgt sarà snoop dogg sera
mi sa che non ci sono più
li mortacci sua non ce la faccio regali
ne mi riesce difficile non so per il
diario tipo inchinarmi prima a ok niente
come non detto ragazzi vai vai vai zio
mezzi ove zio velino lazio
vado e vabbè i muri invisibili sono
sempre ben accetti illuminati con prove
che è primis fa parte degli illuminati
va bene fammi vedere questo trovo today
i'm il proprio primo ep luisa 11 lettere
è più di zucca i 11 è più vista anche
due parole undici meno due
uguale 9 la radice quadrata di 9
e tre gli illuminati hanno tre lati non
avevo dubbi guarda magari queste prove
non sono abbastanza per te no mi ero già
convinto io è però se vuoi continuare
c'è di più guarda la parola happy wings
e li vedi tutti questi triangoli silvio
però devi farti meno pippe mentali e
guarda questo da vedi la scritta total
jack face guarda la forma della bandiera
è un triangolo con fair c'è
un'abbondanza di prove ma non vogliamo
d'argan e altre perché probabilmente
sarei già convinto sì sì mi hai convinto
zio grazie grazie che ho capito che
questo gioco ha un sacco di cose ed
illuminati o no ragazzi ma questo
l'episodio 113 103 il numero 103 a tre
cifre tre cifre come i lati del
triangolo cazzo
ragazzi io non lo sapevo però dovevano
dirmelo prima maledizione io se l'avessi
saputo prima non avrei mai giocato a
questa cosa ormai ci siamo dentro c'è
anche un arpione nel collo quindi
pazienza ragazzi cos'è sta roba slattery
ascelle posso cambiare videogame
mi spiegate perchè ogni tanto crepo così
qual è il problema
no vabbè non so come ho fatto non mi
chiedete come ho fatto ma va bene
comunque questo non livello gli svizzeri
o senza alcun dubbio star wars e come il
film bellissimo regalo
[Applauso]
[Musica]
il so come fanno certi livelli a darmi
così tanta soddisfazione
sono un ragazzo rinato a voi ragazzi
faccio l'ultimo vediamo se riesco a fare
un volto decente come ultimo livello si
prova i ragazzi non lo so perché da un
botto che non fa più ciò singhiozzo ma
prince io quando gioco è più business
il singhiozzo di morte che palle
allora vai vai vai vai veloce help sound
dov'è laddove la vittoria non c'e la
vittoria win come ci arrivo non ci
arrivò mai
ma per quanto domandare che culo che
curò va bene va bene ragazzi va bene per
oggi va bene perché ora da ragazzi che
il clock l'episodio finchè va bene
finchè va bene perché poi potrebbe
peggiorare che sarebbe grave niente
ragazzi spero che vide che parla il
signor salentine video perché a fine
video mi devi ragazzi spero che ai video
vi sia piaciuto a come al solito seguito
la cresciuta stato commento ok è
riuscito a trattenerlo non so come 6
viene presentato il documento che mi
piace anche la pagina di facebook e come
dirlo trattare descrizione cazzo però
alla fine sarà se l'avrei city sky da
ieri ci vediamo il prossimo video da
ragazzi come [ __ ] singhiozzo della
lista